[Aplausos]
[Música]
pensábamos que nunca viviríamos una
guerra en pleno siglo 21 cómo es esto
posible lo sé todo el mundo ha dicho
esto en algún momento de las últimas
semanas todo el mundo pensaba que las
guerras eran cosa del pasado parecía que
el espíritu pacifista de john lennon nos
había poseído a todos los europeos
incluido a vladimir putin pero recordad
a todos john lennon le llega su yoko ono
y el momento yo con europeo ha sido la
invasión de ucrania de repente el
consenso anti militarista en la unión
europea ha desaparecido entramos en una
nueva era con noticias como esta
alemania va a aumentar el gasto militar
en un giro histórico prácticamente todos
los gobiernos europeos están haciendo
anuncios similares y si esto es todo un
giro copernicano en la unión europea
porque europa lleva décadas gastando muy
poco dinero en defensa y cuando digo muy
poco dinero quiere decir menos de lo que
deberían según los acuerdos de la otan
según la carta fundacional de la otan
todos los estados miembros deberían
gastar al menos un 2% de su producto
interior bruto en seguridad sin embargo
atentos a este mapa
hola
los países que aparecen en rojo son los
que no cumplen con los compromisos de la
otan como podéis ver salvo francia
polonia hay unos pocos más casi nadie
los cumple y así ha ocurrido desde hace
casi 30 años por si alguien se lo
preguntaba no el coronavirus no tiene
nada que ver con esto básicamente tras
la caída del telón de acero todos los
países europeos han reducido en términos
relativos sus presupuestos de defensa
año tras año conclusión europa no está
preparada para resistir un posible
ataque de rusia y todo esto explica por
qué a vladimir putin se ha atrevido a
impedir ucrania mientras esperaba que
europa se quedara mirando de brazos
cruzados así que la pregunta ahora es de
dónde va a salir todo ese dinero para
financiar tantísimo gasto militar puede
ser esto una oportunidad dorada para las
empresas europeas hasta qué punto la
amenaza de putin puede ser toda una
oportunidad sí sí una oportunidad única
para que europa deje de estancarse
económicamente hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes vamos a
hablar de defensa pero defensa de
nuestro ordenador o de nuestro teléfono
móvil como ya sabéis internet está lleno
de hackers rusos y hackers de todas
partes del mundo y una buena forma de
evitar buena parte de estos hackers es
usando una vpn
es la vpn favorita de visual político
exacto surf shark vpn creedme el tema de
la ciberseguridad se lo toma muy en
serio por ejemplo surf shark tiene una
herramienta que se llama clean web que
bloquea todos los popups de propaganda
por donde se cuelan todos esos bots y
cookies que francamente no queremos
tener por si todo esto fuera poco con
una única cuenta de surf shark vpn
podrás registrar todos los dispositivos
que quieras quieres navegar con
seguridad desde tu teléfono móvil desde
tu ordenador portátil o desde tu smart
tv pues puedes hacer todo eso con una
única cuenta de surf shark vpn y por
supuesto tenemos una oferta muy especial
para todos vosotros que seguís visual
polític básicamente si utilizáis el
código político terminado en acá podéis
disfrutar de un 83% de descuento más
tres meses extra totalmente gratuitos no
esperéis más creo que la situación
actual ya nos está enseñando una valiosa
lección más vale prevenir que curar y
descargaros los links que encontraréis
en la descripción y ahora sí vamos a ver
un poco de historia
[Aplausos]
cuando éramos pacifistas
en el año 2018 donald trump amenazó con
sacar a eeuu de la otan y haber cumplido
su amenaza la otan se habría
desintegrado en ese momento y creedme
muchos otros líderes mundiales en aquel
momento lo habrían celebrado por
aquellos años el presidente francés
emmanuel macrón llegó a decir que el
estado de la otan era de muerte cerebral
en estos momentos supongo que patrón
estará deseando que nadie le recuerde
sus palabras porque hay que reconocer en
ese momento preciso en el año 2018 trump
si tenía una parte de razón ya sabéis
que aquí en visual politics siempre
fuimos muy críticos con la
administración de trump pero en este
aspecto concreto hizo una llamada a la
atención muy importante casi ningún
miembro de la otan estaba cumpliendo con
sus compromisos de gasto militar a fin
de cuentas porque iban a hacerlo todos
sabían que en caso de amenaza contaban
con el apoyo del 'tío sam' por ejemplo
en este gráfico podéis ver el gasto
militar en alemania
se fija en los años 60 alemania que
estaba casi el 6% de su pib en defensa
durante los años 70 y 80 ese gasto fue
bajando hasta llegar al 2 56 por ciento
en 1990 y justo a partir de 1990 es
decir cuando cae el telón de acero baja
dramáticamente hasta quedarse en poco
más del 1% y la misma tendencia se puede
ver en casi todos los demás países de
europa a estas alturas la pregunta que
todos estáis haciendo es porque de
repente todos los europeos se dieron la
mano y se pusieron a cantar el imagine
de john lennon mientras arrojaban sus
armas al mar pues no exactamente
pensadlo bien para qué se creó la otan
porque eeuu gastaban tanto armamento en
los años 80 pues muy sencillo porque
había una amenaza real la de la unión
soviética sin embargo con la unión
soviética disuelta para que había que
gastar más en armamento no os
equivoquéis europa ha tenido guerras
recientes por ejemplo los millennials
que veáis este vídeo habéis vivido al
menos una guerra la de los balcanes
guerra en la que por cierto terminó
participando la otan sin embargo en la
guerra de los balcanes no había ninguna
gran superpotencia con bombas nucleares
en vuelta las grandes guerras
tradicionales parecían una cosa
y tras el 11 de septiembre el nuevo
enemigo número uno del mundo libre pasó
a ser el terrorismo de repente los malos
de la película dejarán de ser señores
como este a ser señores como este otro y
durante todo el siglo 21 todos los foros
de defensa empezaron a hablar de nuevos
conceptos como lucha antiterrorista
ciberseguridad o guerra híbrida
[Música]
créeme si os digo que esto no es una
opinión nuestra atentos a esta encuesta
aquí podéis ver como en el año 2021 la
principal prioridad militar en europa
era el norte de áfrica seguida de
oriente medio pensando bien luchar
contra una banda como al qaeda o el daes
es todo un desafío pero es un desafío
barato no hacen falta portaaviones ni
submarinos nucleares que es lo realmente
claro en un ejército dicho de otra forma
que muy pocos pensaban que fuera
necesario el gasto militar de hecho
incluso algunos se atrevían a decir
auténticas barbaridades como estas pero
sánchez sobre el ministerio de defensa y
falta presupuesto contra la pobreza
habéis oído bien para quien no lo
conozca pedro sánchez es el presidente
del gobierno de españa en la actualidad
si es verdad que dijo esta frase cuando
todavía era candidato para las
elecciones pero sirve para ilustrar el
sentimiento general en toda europa
durante los últimos 20 años los
gobiernos europeos no sólo han reducido
el presupuesto militar además han usado
el ejército para tareas que tienen muy
poco que ver con la defensa por ejemplo
en el año 2005 españa creó la unidad de
emergencias militares que es una especie
de cuerpo de bomberos que se paga con el
presupuesto de defensa y hay unidades
enteras que han dejado de entrenarse
para el combate y han pasado a hacer las
humanitarias ojo esto no es una crítica
a la labor humanitaria ni a los cuerpos
de rescate ya sabéis que aquí en visual
político tenemos un respeto sagrado por
las fuerzas armadas pero los hechos son
claros
casi toda europa se ha tomado la defensa
como si fuera una broma incluso hemos
llegado a ver propuestas tan
descacharrantes como esta a una política
de seguridad y defensa a prueba del
cambio climático una ruta de acción para
la unión europea si habéis oído bien en
algún momento a alguien en bruselas se
le ocurrió que el cambio temático
debería ser una prioridad en el ejército
y a ver no me malinterpretéis aquí no
estamos diciendo que el cambio climático
no sea importante pero en caso de guerra
ya de verdad hace un esfuerzo imaginaos
ahora en ucrania a alguien comprando
balas para sus metralletas y diciéndote
oiga pero me las pone que sean
biodegradables dicho de otra forma
durante 30 años toda europa estaba
convencida de que ya no existirían más
guerras suena ridículo pues seamos
honestos si suena ridículo ahora pero si
hubiéramos publicado este vídeo hace
tres semanas muchos nos acusarían en los
comentarios de alarmistas sin embargo
todo esto ha cambiado putin ha enterrado
john lennon y también a yoko ono como
pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
si quieres la paz prepárate para la
guerra
lo hemos dicho varias veces en los
últimos días putin ya ha perdido la
guerra da igual lo que ocurre en ucrania
porque el objetivo de vladimir putin era
acabar con la amenaza de la otan durante
años parecía que realmente se iba a
salir con la suya sin embargo la
invasión de ucrania lo ha cambiado todo
atentos más neutrales suecia y finlandia
reconsidera la idea de entrar en la otan
y esto es sólo el principio los países
bálticos ya han pedido a eeuu que ponga
a bases militares en sus países y no
esto no es que eeuu haya dicho o me
gustaría poner una base militar en
estonia no ha sido el propio gobierno de
estonia el que ha dicho por favor poned
bases militares por que tenemos miedo de
ser los siguientes después de ucrania
alemania ya ha dicho que va a duplicar
su gasto militar pero no sólo eso el
canciller alemán olaf scholz ha llegado
a decir que quiere cambiar la
constitución para incluir el gasto de
defensa del 2% del pib en otras palabras
que hemos pasado de escuchar a john
lennon para ponernos a escuchar a sábato
[Música]
la pregunta ahora es quién va a pagar el
concierto porque si es muy fácil decir
gastemos más en defensa pero qué
significa eso vamos a comprar más
aviones contratar más soldados pues
atentos un estudio apunta que el
ejército alemán sigue sufriendo escasez
de recursos el informe del que hablamos
no es un informe cualquiera es un
informe encargado por el parlamento
alemán donde se llega a decir que
ninguno de los submarinos y cazas de
combate alemanes está o estaba listo
para el combate todos ellos están o
estaban en reparación o ni siquiera
tenían combustible para zarpar dicho de
otra forma que si rusia hubiera atacado
en ese momento no habría forma de
responder al menos hasta varias semanas
después
y esto no es algo único de alemania
básicamente casi todos los ejércitos
europeos tienen el mismo problema el
poco armamento que tienen está guardado
en hangares porque pues porque mantener
un caza de combate para que esté listo
para el combate es caro muy caro y sin
dinero no hay nada que hacer pues bien
es muy probable que esta sea una de las
primeras prioridades de europa lo que
llamaríamos el alistamiento por supuesto
también cabe esperar compras de material
nuevo os acordáis de los cazas f-35 de
los que tantas veces hemos hablado aquí
en visual polític pues todo apunta a que
veremos muchos más f-35 en los ejércitos
europeos no os equivoquéis esto no se
debe a la presión de eeuu esto se debe a
que tras décadas de presupuestos
raquíticos en defensa europa tiene muy
pocas empresas de armamento que
realmente puedan competir con las
americanas así que a día de hoy si
quieres un caza de combate de último
modelo no te queda otra que comprar el
f-35
pero esperad un momento porque ya sé lo
que estaréis pensando mucho sobre todo
vosotros los que hayáis llegado a este
vídeo desde la comunidad de asuntos
militares que ya sé que sois muchos por
fin nos escuchan pues si tenéis razón
por fin os escuchan pero aquí viene la
pregunta que todavía nadie se está
haciendo de dónde va a venir todo el
dinero para financiar todo esto pensadlo
así la lista de prioridades urgentes de
vida o muerte y emergencias
existenciales en europa es más larga que
nunca hace dos años tuvimos el cómic 19
que se tradujo en más impuestos y más
deuda la receta para salir de la crisis
del cobi ha sido esta nueva agenda verde
para acabar con la emergencia climática
traducción más impuestos y más deuda
ahora resulta que también tenemos la
amenaza de rusia que se traducirá en
efectivamente más impuestos y más deuda
y si a esto le sumamos la inflación la
subida liana que ya estamos sufriendo y
que todo apunta que vamos a seguir
sufriendo durante los próximos meses
tenemos un panorama bastante sombrío
para los europeos así que la pregunta es
que se puede hacer pues aquí vamos con
una idea
[Música]
pájaros de un tiro'
porque no hay un google europeo si nos
hemos hecho esta pregunta a un millón de
veces aquí en visual político y seamos
claros este es el problema de europa sin
innovación ni empresas punteras no hay
crecimiento económico que valga y sin
una economía que funcione no hay gasto
social ni lucha contra el cambio
climático ni mucho menos gasto en
defensa la pregunta es por qué por qué
europa siempre se queda atrás en todas
las nuevas revoluciones tecnológicas
internet redes sociales inteligencia
artificial aún no dirá es que iba a
batir impuestos muy altos pero realmente
si nos ponemos a comparar país por país
estonia no tiene impuestos más altos que
california por ejemplo seguridad
jurídica pues es que europa tiene
seguridad jurídica pues bien una de las
muchas razones que explican la falta de
innovación en europa es el ejército
[Música]
si he escuchado bien el ejército con
mejor dicho la poca inversión en las
fuerzas armadas por supuesto no es la
única razón ni tampoco quizás la más
importante pero si es relevante pensando
bien tanto israel como corea del sur
como los propios eeuu son países
tecnológicamente avanzadísimos en buena
medida gracias a su ejército silicon
valley nació gracias entre otros motivos
a que el ejército estableció justo ahí
un centro de desarrollo de
telecomunicaciones
[Música]
de hecho internet el propio internet
nació como un proyecto de defensa de
eeuu y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
muchos en serio desde cuando el estado
puede promover la y más de de forma
efectiva todos lo sabemos cada vez que
un gobierno quiere desarrollar una
tecnología concreta fracasa
miserablemente lo vemos todos los días
sin ir más lejos en la unión europe con
programas como por ejemplo el horizon
europe que se dedica a financiar
proyectos de investigación sobre el
papel es una idea fantástica pero no
queréis investigarlo a fondo porque por
ejemplo os voy a dar un ejemplo real
hemos podido ver personalmente desde
visual política no voy a dar nombres
pero creedme si os digo que esto es un
caso real
en el año 2018 una universidad europea
desarrolló un sistema para crear prensas
de biomasa prensas fáciles de construir
que permitían comprimir basura y
convertirla en pelets que generas en
energía de forma muy eficiente la
investigación era tan buena que llegó a
recibir un premio nacional el problema
el problema es que han pasado cuatro
años desde la finalización de este
proyecto y todavía está por ver si algún
día se construirá una prensa de biomasa
basada en los diseños de este proyecto
ni siquiera se ha llegado a sacar una
patente que pueda comprar una empresa
cualquiera es un bonito taco de papel
que está en una estantería en algún
lugar de bruselas porque a fin de
cuentas quien se va a molestar en
convertir esa nueva tecnología en un
producto realmente útil para la sociedad
nadie porque pues porque nadie tiene el
incentivo para hacerlo y como este hay
mil ejemplos más
[Música]
además de militar en cambio es bastante
diferente en este caso los propios
estados tienen un incentivo muy grande
para crear armas con las que competir
con el enemigo así que la jmas de se
canaliza sobre todo a propuestos
aplicados por supuesto que también hay
grandes sobrecostos en la jmas de de
defensa ahí está por ejemplo el f-35 en
el que hemos dado buena cuenta a quien
visual polític pero incluso en este caso
el resultado final es el caza de combate
más letal del momento
[Música]
es caro si es tremendamente caro pero es
un arma que no tiene rival al menos
rival que se conozca y muchas de las
tecnologías que se han desarrollado para
crear el f-35 seguro que darán lugar a
un montón de startups para uso civil
dicho de otra forma gastar en defensa
tiene una utilidad civil por eso no
sería nada descabellado proponer que
buena parte de este nuevo gasto militar
no venga de nuevos impuestos sino de
otras partidas de gasto que se
destinaban a la investigación civil en
otras palabras que los mismos fondos que
ahora van a parar a proyectos civiles
ahora pueden ir a parar a proyectos
militares que tarde o temprano tendrán
una utilidad civil
es decir que el gasto militar en
innovación tiende a ser mucho más
aplicado que el resto de partidas
públicas en imax de esta precisamente es
una de las razones por las que israel
con un cast en defensa del 5,6 por
ciento de su pib sea también la nación
de las startups en este caso el ejército
ha servido para galvanizar la innovación
en otros sectores así que puestos a
gastar la jmas de militar puede cosechar
mejores resultados que otras opciones
así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros veremos algún día nuevas
subidas de impuestos en europa para
pagar gasto militar o todo este gasto
militar vendrá de otras partidas de
gasto hasta qué punto la amenaza de
rusia podría ser de verdad una
oportunidad de oro para que algún día
surja ese google europeo que tanta falta
hace podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en
los comentarios y como siempre no
olvidéis que aquí en visual político
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas
así que suscribirse a este canal y darle
a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un saludo y hasta
pronto
[Música]